unlike 20 years ago or 10 years ago it's
less uncool to publicly profess your
Christianity I find that very
interesting I think there's a Martin
Guri line he says something when people
give up on the city of man they turn
back to the city of God and it seems to
me that that is the positive I guess
that's reformational in a sense it is it
is I mean I I often find myself thinking
about you know the prognosis for public
Christianity we attend our local
Anglican Church which is it's in the
same doldrums as most Anglican churches
I was looking around and I was thinking
is it just over and actually I don't
think so I think it may well be over for
the Church of England as a public
political institution in the role it's
played in Britain's political systems
really since
since since Henry VIII did what he did
that may well be over but I don't think
the Christian faith is over I just don't
because it's had years in the wilderness
before and
here we still are you know 2000 years
later